I hope everybody had a good Memorial Day
weekend if you live in the United States
and you uh had a day off on Monday you
know I received many emails over the
weekend about the debt ceiling and the
bill that may have been reached to avoid
defaulting on U.S debt and many of you
were saying David why haven't you been
covering this why aren't you covering
this and it is true other than I believe
it was just one story on the world
famous award-winning bonus show I have
not spoken about the debt ceiling debate
controversy whatever you want to call it
and that has not been by accident it's
been on purpose and I want to explain to
you why and then I want to hear from you
does this make sense or should I have
been talking about it all along now as a
reminder the debt ceiling is the legal
limit on how much the federal government
can borrow to pay its bills and
importantly it has nothing to do with
new spending when we talk about the debt
ceiling we're talking about borrowing to
to honor prior obligations already
approved by Congress so when people want
to debate well we should allow the U.S
to default because I'm against the
inflation reduction act or whatever the
case may be this is not about debating
new spending this is about meeting
obligations for already approved
spending and there are four reasons that
I have made the deliberate choice and
they all have to do with respect for you
in the audience four reasons why I
haven't been covering this now first of
all
the same thing happens every time and
this alone isn't a reason not to talk
about something things in politics will
happen more than once or at least
they'll happen almost identically more
than once but every time the debt
ceiling is reached and that happens
regularly because the government runs a
deficit you see Republicans threatening
to block its increase unless they get
concessions from Democrats they talk
about writing checks we can't cash they
talk about spending cuts they talk about
policy issues and it creates drama and
uncertainty but it is mostly a political
stunt
and I'm being clear here from the point
of view of Republicans talking about
defaulting Republicans know that the U.S
can't actually be allowed to default on
its debt because it would be
catastrophic to both the American
economy and to the reputation of
Republicans now if they could get away
with it with somehow Democrats getting
blamed maybe they would go for it but
they also know it would be bad for many
of their constituents to allow the U.S
to default and that they would get at
least some of the blame if not all so
they eventually cave and they agree to
raise the debt ceiling sometimes it's at
the last minute after a temporary
extension it's the same routine time and
again so it's happened many many times
and it is happening now secondly it's
all bad for the American people and what
I mean by that is not the defaulting
that might happen which would of course
be bad but the debt ceiling debate is
bad for the American people as a
narrative and a storyline it's not only
pointless it's also harmful it wastes
time and resources that could be spent
on actual important issues like new
infrastructure programs or getting
people Health Care climate change it
undermines The credibility and the
stability of the United States as a
borrower and a leader in the world the
more we publicize this absurd Antiquated
retro grade system which gets us to
these debt ceiling debates in the first
place the Dumber we look on the global
stage it's unnecessary it creates
volatility and risk in the financial
markets that hurts everybody
even people not in the markets just
straight up consumers it increases the
cost of borrowing for the government
that adds to the debt burden even more
in the long run and according to some
estimates the debt ceiling crises of
2011 and 2013 actually pushed interest
rates up somewhere between half a point
and two points costing taxpayers
billions of dollars so I don't want to
participate in worsening that situation
number three they eventually come to an
agreement despite the theatrics and the
grandstanding and the brinkmanship and
the entire thing both parties know
sooner or later you're going to have to
raise the debt ceiling and what they try
to get in the meantime is screen time
which I'll get to or concessions which
may or may not actually make any sense
they they can't afford to let the US
default on its obligations which could
trigger a financial meltdown a potential
recession they also don't want to face
backlash from voters at the end of the
day and from businesses who would suffer
in such a scenario so they strike a deal
it involves some minor concessions or
compromises the concessions or
compromises aren't significant enough to
say that's why it was good that they
were holding out and it fundamentally
changes nothing
about the fiscal situation or the
underlying situation in which we find
ourselves and lastly it's an attempt for
politicians to cynically get attention
during negotiations look at how many
stories there were about McCarthy's
heading to the White House to meet with
Biden and then they're sitting there the
debt ceiling debate is not actually
about fiscal responsibility the way
Republicans love to claim it's not
really about Economic Policy either
because the policies that get us to this
situation every however many months also
aren't being discussed in any serious
way it's about posturing and messaging
can I get a meeting with the president
can I as a republican accuse Democrats
of being fiscally irresponsible
everybody's trying to score points with
the base and attack their opponents and
I guess get some leverage to maybe get
some extra concessions or Advance their
agenda somewhere else some Republicans
have been trying to link the debt
ceiling to blocking the infrastructure
plan or reversing some Biden executive
orders so the reasons that I haven't
covered it are because in order to cover
it in the way that it is mostly being
covered I have to insult my Audience by
pretending that there is something
different going on than the exact same
thing that always goes on and it becomes
a distraction from more important urgent
matters that affect our lives and our
future now I won't deny
if the U.S did default on its debt and
did not raise the debt ceiling it would
be now not only globally chaotic it
would start to affect individuals who
are waiting on certain government
payments and in other situations I don't
deny that but the point is I don't
believe that that's actually at risk of
happening for any significant period of
time more than a few days at the end of
the day what could I possibly add to the
normal debate about the debt ceiling
this segment is the real analysis which
is it's an analysis of the way that the
debt ceiling is discussed the way that
the debt ceiling debate
is portrayed in media and used cynically
by our elected officials but there's
really nothing for me to add to that
this is the real analysis agree or
disagree I want to hear from you and I
haven't been covering it fundamentally
out of respect for my audience